en el vídeo anterior hablamos de la
teoría de colisión y dijimos que las
moléculas deben colisionar para
reaccionar también dijimos que esas
colisiones deben tener la orientación
correcta para que sean efectivas y
finalmente esas colisiones deben tener
la energía suficiente para que ocurra la
reacción y todas estas ideas están
involucradas en esta ecuación la
ecuación de arrhenius donde k es la
constante de velocidad
de la que hablamos en la ley de
velocidad
a es el factor de frecuencia o también
se le conoce como el factor pre
exponencial ésta indica la frecuencia de
las colisiones y también la orientación
de las mismas después tenemos esta
elevada a la menos el subíndice a sobre
rt que corresponde a la fracción de
colisiones con la energía suficiente
para que la reacción pueda ocurrir y
todo esto lo podemos simbolizar con una
f minúscula
efe depende de la energía de activación
que debe estar en llull sobre mol r es
la constante de los gases ideales y t es
la temperatura en grados kelvin veamos
qué pasa con la fracción de colisiones
al variar la energía de activación y la
temperatura de una reacción empecemos
con una energía de activación de 40
kilos urss por mol
la temperatura de 373 kelvin entonces
queremos saber efe
así que f es igual a a elevada a menos
la energía de activación en jules formol
pero como la tenemos en kilos urss por
mol necesitamos convertirla esto es
igual a 40.000 tours por mol entre la
constante de los gases que es igual a
8.314 jules sobre kelvin mol y esto
multiplica por la temperatura que es de
373 kelvin entonces 373 kelvin ahora
observen que todas las unidades se
cancelen y para el cálculo usemos la
calculadora
elevada a la menos 40 mil 123 entre
8.300 14 por 373 esto es igual a 2.5 por
10 a la menos 6 entonces esto es igual a
2.5 por 10 a la menos 6 y eso qué
significa
bueno supongamos que tenemos un millón
de colisiones un millón de colisiones
que número dividido entre un millón es
igual a 2.5 por 10 a la menos 6 bueno
2.5 2.5 entre un millón es igual a 2.5
por 10 a la menos 6 esto significa que
por cada millón de colisiones solo
2.5 colisiones tienen la energía
suficiente para reaccionar aunque este
es un número muy pequeño ahora veamos lo
que sucede cuando cambiamos la energía
de activación de 40 kilos jules por mol
a 10 kilos jules por mol disminuimos la
energía de activación pero mantenemos la
temperatura constante
veamos cómo afecta esto a nuestra efe
esta vez
efe es igual a el elevada y ahora
tenemos menos 10.000 / 8.314 por 373
usemos la calculadora ahora tenemos a
elevada a menos 10.000 / 8.314 por 373 y
esto es igual a 0.04 entonces esto es
igual a 0.04 y observen que hemos
aumentado el valor de f pasamos de 2.5
por 10 a la menos 6 a 0.04 ahora
volvamos a suponer que ocurre en un
millón de colisiones un millón que el
número dividido entre un millón es igual
a 0.04 bueno ese número es 40 mil 40.000
entre un millón es igual a 0.04 así que
por cada millón de colisiones que
ocurran en la reacción 40.000 de
tienen la energía suficiente para
reaccionar eso es un gran aumento y lo
logramos disminuyendo la energía de
activación entonces al disminuir la
energía de activación aumentamos el
valor de f el número de colisiones
efectivas muy bien ahora veamos uno en
donde cambiamos la temperatura
esta vez mantenemos la energía de
activación constante de 10 kilos urss
por mol
pero antes teníamos una temperatura de
373 kelvin y ahora la aumentamos a 473
veamos cómo afecta esto al valor de f
entonces
es igual a y elevada a menos 10.000 /
8.314 por 473 usemos la calculadora
elevada a menos 10.000 / 8.314 por 473
esto es igual a si lo redondeamos 0.08
entonces esto es igual a 0.08 así que
hemos incrementado el valor de f de 0.04
a 0.08 y volvamos a suponer que tenemos
un millón de colisiones así es más fácil
entender lo que significa
quién número dividido entre un millón es
igual a 0.08 bueno debe ser 80.000
entonces por cada millón de colisiones
que ocurran 80.000 de ellas tendrán la
energía suficiente para reaccionar así
que al aumentar la temperatura de 373 a
473 incrementamos el número de
colisiones con la energía suficiente
para reaccionar incrementamos el valor
de f
finalmente veamos qué ocurre con la
constante de velocidad regresemos a
nuestra ecuación de arrhenius estuvimos
hablando de efe y para incrementar el
valor de f necesitamos disminuir la
energía de activación o podemos aumentar
la temperatura entonces al disminuir la
energía de activación aumentamos el
valor de f
y lo mismo ocurre al aumentar la
temperatura
ahora si aumentamos el valor de f
entonces aumentamos el valor de k
aumentamos el valor de la constante de
velocidad y recuerde como vimos en la
ley de velocidad r es igual a la
constante de velocidad k por la
concentración de los reactivos de la
reacción observen que la velocidad de
reacción es directamente proporcional a
la constante de velocidad k así que
cuando aumentamos la constante de
velocidad acá estamos aumentando la
velocidad de la reacción
entonces si disminuimos la energía de
activación o si aumentamos la
temperatura aumentamos la fracción de
colisiones con la energía suficiente
para que la reacción pueda ocurrir por
lo tanto aumenta la constante de
velocidad acá y como acá está
directamente relacionada con la
velocidad
y también aumentamos la velocidad de la
reacción y esto tiene sentido porque
sabemos que al aumentar la temperatura
de una reacción aumentamos la velocidad
de esa reacción
por eso las ideas de la teoría de
colisión están involucradas en la
ecuación de arrhenius y veremos más
sobre esto en los siguientes vídeos